hello everybody this is your third
favorite systems design YouTuber Jordan
back at it with another video still
hungover at 4 P.M on a Saturday so
hoping to get through this one kind of
quickly anyways today's we'll be talking
about search indexes which is yet
another Niche type of data store so
let's go ahead and get into it we're
looking at the tail end of the system's
design concept videos now so let's plow
through these and then we can get to
some questions alrighty so at this point
we've spoken about quite a few different
types of problems but today we are going
to address a different one which is
searching specifically probably text
searching so as you can see right here
I've got my beautifully artistically
drawn search bar think of us as on
Amazon and I am searching for tissues as
I often am because I'm frequently
running out of them so we might get a
few options back and as you can see the
word tissues just has to be contained
really in any of the text for that
listing so in this case you know
highlight that guy there as you can see
it doesn't necessarily just have to be
at the start of the term
so databases don't really handle this
problem very well why well our first
instinct might be to make an index or a
secondary index perhaps on this text
field that we're searching for so let's
say we wanted to search the term apple
and so we put an index on our actual
text field right here as you can see and
so that would mean we were sorting them
by the first character of the text and
and so on but in this case even though
Apple starts with a so you would think
that it would be at the top of our index
as you can see we've got this listing
right here which contains the word apple
and it is at the bottom of our index the
reason being that when doing a search
for text that text could be a substring
at any single part of the term and as a
result of that a traditional index isn't
going to work for us here we have to do
something a little bit more intelligent
than that so databases are not going to
solve a problem we need to use a
different type of technology and or data
structure so what are we actually going
to go ahead and do well we're going to
use something known as a search index
and so search indexes are actually
capable of solving our problem in a much
better way the reason for this is they
take a typical document something that
we might see in a database where we've
got something like an ID and a piece of
text that we want to be able to search
later down the line and it does
something called tokenizing We're
tokenizing you know is basically
scrubbing down the text in a way such
that it makes it easier to search down
the line for example if we have the
Apple computer symbol right there with
some sort of like trademark logo we
don't care about that we want to make
this lowercase we want to make this a
lowercase C we don't really care about
our space and so then we end up getting
two different tokens apple and computer
and in what we eventually create we're
going to basically have the actual token
right here
and then all of the document IDs so this
is going to be a list of document IDs
that correspond to it or that contain
that token
and so what this is known as is called
the inverted index and our search index
is effectively an inverted index or
sometimes possibly even multiple
inverted indexes so we can do multiple
interesting cool types of searching so
the example of the introverted index
that we just made is going to help us do
something called prefix searching where
basically you know it's very easy for us
to search for terms based on the prefix
of those terms so here's an example
here's our inverted Index right here
hold on let me be able to draw that so
we've got our inverted index
and let's say we want to search for all
of the documents that have words
starting with the letter c well the nice
thing that we do in our inverted index
in a search index is we actually keep it
sorted so as you can see we've got a
first then B then C then you know
another word with C but is
lexicographically later and so what we
can do now is we can actually binary
search as we would with a typical index
and so we would say oh you know is this
less than C is this greater than C oh
this is less than C so let's look down
here blah blah here are C terms and so
now we know all of the documents where
we have terms with cantaloupe and Cherry
which both start with C which is really
really nice so prefix sorting like I
mentioned super easy with an inverted
index because we're doing all of this
work up front to tell us where all of
the documents are that contain the terms
that we're interested in
another cool thing that we can do is
suffix searching so I gotta make this a
little bit bigger because I'm bad at
making my slides a consistent size so
let's imagine we've got this guy over
here which is like our prefix inverted
index
what we can do is whenever we take in a
new document we can actually keep a
second copy of the inverted index
specifically for searching words by
their suffix so as you can see we've got
Apple over here but what we'll do is
we'll actually reverse that word so
Apple becomes e-l-ppa and we'll put it
in our basically suffix inverted index
and note that even though the order of
the words here is Apple blackberry
blueberry raspberry
in our suffix inverted index we're still
ordering our terms alphabetically so
it's actually Apple then I believe it is
blueberry then it's Blackberry then it's
raspberry so note that this is still
ordered
by suffix
and why does this help us because again
let's say we wanted to search for all of
our fruit that end in the word Berry
this is super easy Berry all we have to
do is reverse it we know that reversing
Berry turns into y r r e b
and then we can binary search our index
for all of the terms that start with y r
r e b which is this guy right here and
so this allows us to really search for
terms that end with a certain suffix so
we get 92 43 19 and then we could join
those on our SQL database or we could
even keep the entire record in our index
itself if we want to lower our latency
at the cost of storing more data
okay so now that we've gone over the
general premise of a search index and
some of the things we could do with it
for both prefix and suffix searching
let's talk about Apache leucine so
Lucian is a very popular open source
search index which is effectively just
built on top of an LSM tree architecture
however the really really nice thing
about it is that in addition to things
like prefix search and suffix search
which are Super basic it supports a
bunch of other complex types of
searching where you can do like
levinstein distance find words that are
close to the word that you typed in
coordinate searching time searching
anything like that and so as a result
it's got all of these really rich
features that make search indexes super
useful in order to greatly speed up
those General searchings as opposed to
searching specifically by an indexed
value and so Lucian is something or
rather it's just a piece of technology
that is going to be super super useful
whenever you're trying to build a search
index of course Lucian is one of those
pieces of technology that typically is
meant to be used on a single node so in
our next video we're going to be talking
about how we might distribute something
like Apache Lucian make a distributed
search index and make it run efficiently
anyways guys I will see you for that one
have a great rest of your day